[Music]
start right in with it um
by introducing brandon farr from copper
rock capital partners
thank you please welcome brandon park
[Applause]
good afternoon and welcome my name is
brandon farr
i'm the lead quantitative researcher at
copper rock capital partners
we are boston-based long-only equity
firm
serving the institutional marketplace
we have clients from around the world
with two-thirds of the money we manage
coming from outside the united states
i started using r in 2005 because it was
the most powerful
analytical tool i'd ever come across
each year ours became more powerful
fifteen years ago our use in finance was
rare
it's become more common but what has
been the impact
let's take a look at this quote from
alliance bernstein
we estimate that at least 99 percent of
so-called fundamental models for
individual companies
manifest themselves in excel
so our industry is still relying on a
tool built for the data challenges of
the 20th century
people use excel because it's easy to
learn
but we as we all know it then takes on a
life of its own
ad hoc solutions end up becoming the
basis for important decisions
but better data analysis requires
reproducibility and scalability
so in preparing for today i decided to
focus on what makes r compelling for
those cases
what's going to dent that 99 percent
i'm going to focus on two important use
cases
first using r to do better analysis
by better analysis i mean
you spend more time interpreting your
data and manipulating it
second using r to build
what you cannot buy in the marketplace
i'll use shiny to make my case
we start with data good analysis is
based on sound data
financial world has many providers
supplying data to help us understand
companies and markets
bloomberg and factset are a couple the
providers that i frequently use
here is apple's price chart in the
bloomberg terminal
in the terminal i can change the time
period data frequency and overlay
calculations onto this chart this is
great but it doesn't scale
how do i look at 10 stocks how do i look
at a portfolio stocks
to do scalable analysis i usually need
to report or analyze what i'll call
reported data mine typically comes from
factset
and is formatted for printing not for
our processing
you can see the header is messy dates
are formatted as text
rows are grouped together but r allows
us to do good data analysis even when we
start with messy data
let's look at a typical scenario
as an investment team we need to know
what is driving markets
here is data from the fourth quarter of
last year
these are sector performance reports for
the us and global markets
in the spreadsheet i get from factset
this data comes separated into tabs
and the stock data is grouped by sector
and hidden because
everything has been collapsed now tables
of data are useful
but visualizations are better
with a chart we can quickly see that
healthcare and technology
drove both the u.s and world markets in
the fourth quarter
this is hard to pull from tabular data
especially if it's on separate tabs
so how would we visualize this in excel
well i would do something like this
i'd gather the data into a single tab
making sure everything's aligned so that
if i'm
labeling data the labels are
appropriately placed
i'd create a plot referencing the group
totals
and then i'd customize the plot i'm sure
most of you have done something similar
to this
and are aware that pitfalls lie ahead
it's my experience that anything that's
useful leads to further questions
is our excel process up to the task of
answering further
questions okay fine
but what worked in the emerging markets
did healthcare and technology lead in
the fourth quarter of 2018 as well
how do we answer these questions with
our excel process
well i'll argue that just in one
additional tab of data is going to
require me to rework my entire process
if i need to turn this around quickly
which i often do i can only hope that
i'll be accurate
to ensure that i'm accurate i probably
need to start over
the excel solution just feels fragile
my sense is that even if you are very
good at plumbing in excel
extending an established process is
burden burdensome
fraught with error and probably requires
a lot of repetition
this is a major hurdle to doing better
better data analysis
so how does r help us do this analysis
in a better way
well in r i'm going to complete the same
steps but i'm going to do it in a
structured way with code
i'll specify the data file i will read
and prepare the market data
i will collect the group information and
then i'll plot those groups
r allows us to break a process into
logical distinct
steps with proper naming the logic of
the process is explicit
and readable with care when we need to
extend this process
nothing needs to change let me walk
through the code
let's take a minute to look at how easy
setting up robust processes has become
and are
this is important because we are trying
to convince ourselves and others to do
the same sort of analysis in our do more
of it remember
remember we're trying to put a dent in
that 99 percent
this is the heart of our process here
here we see good examples of
names indicating function and logical
separation
of tasks
so let's look at the function prepare
market data
our function reads the tab names from
the file and puts them into a table
next we make calls to read grouped data
with the help of mutate and map
after this step we have a table with two
rows representing the two markets in our
analysis with all of the underlying
data conveniently stored in list columns
this is a very powerful structure and an
example of something that wasn't
possible 15 years ago even in r
but how did group regroup data handle
all the messiness of our data
though reported data is often messy it
is usually consistent
by taking advantage of the patterns we
observe in the spreadsheet file we can
systematically handle
the collapsed data here we see sector
and company names occupy separate
columns
in the spreadsheet plus the sector group
row stands on its own
healthcare shown here is not carried
down the column so in this
representation
healthcare or group membership is
implied with r we make it explicit
this is a good example of how and clear
it is in code when we are manipulating
data
all we need to look for in this case is
mutate commands
copy and paste manipulation is
documented nowhere
additionally a functional additionally a
function like this
is a perfect candidate for a package so
can be reused across many analyses
collect groups is just a simple function
that unnests the list columns
and then filters to just give me the
group total rows
if you guys haven't seen this pattern
it's one that's very powerful
note that we will maintain the natural
relationships between
the market names and the underlying
market data automatically
finally we pipe to a plotting function
that captures all of our logic
so we have encapsulated the entirety of
our data process into four functions
none more than seven or eight lines long
and all very readable
this is better analysis with the r with
r we get reliability
our process is replicable replicable and
efficient because we aren't copying
and pasting errors or future changes can
be traced
to the impacted steps and corrected or
implemented
in my experience processes set up in
this way typically fail
not because of coding problems but
because of data changes
a quick aside last week i was asked the
specifics of how i performed a what-if
analysis on some of our historic
portfolio holdings it had been months
since i had done the work
and yet within two minutes of reviewing
the code i was able to answer the
question
accurately and confidently if i'd done
the work in excel
i would have had no chance
next i'd like to show you how we have
used r and shiny at copper rock to build
something we couldn't buy
our quantitative model covers over 10
000 stocks
in the past we deliver this to analysts
and portfolio managers
in an excel spreadsheet
here's an example of one of the weekly
files
it only contains the most recent data
it's frustrating to filter when you
apply filters in excel you can't
understand the logic the best you can
tell is whether or not a
a column has a filter applied to it or
not
it's difficult to see the relationship
between groups of stocks
and it's it's difficult to integrate
this data with other data from our
vendors
so we created cognos cognos is a shiny
app built to meet our team's
specific analytical needs nothing
available from bloomberg or factset
matches it
even though we are a small focused shop
r and shiny has allowed us to create
this powerful custom application
let's take a closer look
here is a snapshot of microsoft through
the lens of our quantitative model
our model data indicated indicated here
comes from microsoft azure database
we pull in data from bloomberg via their
their api
and msci esg data is sourced from flat
files
all of this data provides the context
that was missing from our excel based
solution data is no longer siloed
analysts don't have to make the
connection cognos is doing it for them
just seeing the data in the middle of
the screen moved our conversations from
conjecture to data
based reality we no longer had to rely
on the recollection that
oh the model has always liked microsoft
cognos can tell us
and the orange line tells us it hasn't
always liked microsoft
on this screen you see two important
components of our quantitative model
represented in the scatter
plot higher scores should indicate
better stocks
we've found it most productive to
reserve our fundamental research for
highly ranked stocks
so by focusing on stocks in the first
quadrant analysts can better allocate
their research time
with the interactivity of shiny apps our
analysts quickly navigate their way
through a massive universe
cognos really helps them kick start
their analysis
it is used by our team all day long
r and shiny helped us build something we
couldn't buy
cognos has become our hub for data
delivery
is naturally extensible needs no
training
and requires very few its resources
so we walked through an example of how
easy it is to set up a process to do
better analysis in r
then we looked at how shiny apps can
help you build something you can't buy
match to the exactly the way your team
works
i think it is a great example of how a
relatively simple
shiny app can have a significant impact
recall my focus for today was to make a
dent in the 99
i think these two use cases are examples
of how we might start
i encourage you all to chip in
thank you very much for your time and
attention i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you brandon uh just a reminder
that you can ask questions on
uh on slido a couple questions
from william chu data table is
multi-threaded and very fast what are
the performance metrics between arrow
and data table
oh is this a different oh sorry i got
the wrong room sorry
well come on man
all right well i've got one for you what
is the uh what what package
new package are you most excited about
um
well as i said i think i think i'm just
excited about all the changes happening
in in the tidy verse dplyer that that
that pattern of being able to read
either the tabs of an excel spreadsheet
or files that you would get from calling
durr on a directory
and using that to be the starting point
for a tibble
which then you use map to pull all the
data in
just allows you to naturally keep either
file locations names and data all
together
and then it flows naturally through the
rest of the process so i literally just
started just using that
um a month or two ago and and
uh uh enjoy it quite a bit i think
that's
so i've used r for 15 years um
uh i don't think gg plot 2 was out we
had
plier and and reshape
and you know i think that
what can happen as you work as you work
you get set in one way of doing things
and it's difficult to get off
those patterns so this pattern may be
old to you guys but
to me it's been a great refresher to to
my work and
that i do great thank you another
question
um what led you to the use of list
columns instead of multiple tables at
different levels
um two thoughts
attending our studio conf and listening
to jenny bryan talk about them
with the lego characters but
it's also just to me it it just makes it
easy to think about the data because it
is
if i need to get into the details i can
i can go get it but very often i want to
work at that summary
level and if something spread across
multiple tables then
to do that work i might need to do joins
just even for exploratory analysis
nice and uh you mentioned that you're
working with factset data and i assume
other vendors
and when that the format of that data
challenge it changes is that a challenge
and how do you deal with that challenge
yeah
so i i mentioned that the the this
process that i laid out is robust
typically to code errors but
but not to data uh data data file
formats changing
example depending on uh when you come in
factset will either have seven or eight
rows in the the header column
uh or seven or eight rows in the header
of a file
and so that used to kill if that was
hard coded in a bunch of different areas
in your code that would kill
kill the code but now like i said
taking that reading or processing code
and separating into a single function
and then reusing that function if it
changes i make the change once and
and i can use it going forward it's also
something obviously that's obvious for a
um not to have as a parameter in in the
function call
thank you and um have you considered
almost getting political democratizing r
across the firm outside of your
immediate group and i think the
as an example of replacing excel um with
usage by analysts and if you have or
have not
where's the friction you're seeing from
that sure so cognos is the first step
there
um when i got to to copper rock
that quantitative model that we
delivered every every week as a 10 000
row spreadsheet was actually printed out
and people would print it front and back
open it
use rulers to scan and find it so that
was the use the the level of user i was
starting with so
to jump right into uh coding was not
going to happen but
i think cognos is the first step there
and then i've started more in meetings
because of the readability of dplyr code
actually
dynamically answering questions with the
code rather than saying i'll get back to
you and i hope that
as people see me do that the code's up
on the screen they'll start to become
more interested
okay there's a related question here uh
about delivering data to uh to non-r
users in the org
is excel the only way that you're doing
that or are there other ways
um we do we do some
via microsoft outlook uh emails but
that's
it's very rudimentary it's a flat text
file so it's not very
i haven't um i forget what the r studio
um mailing uh package is so
i haven't used last blastula um
and yeah i think that that's that's it
so it's excel and it's uh cognos it's on
10 desktops i mean so it's
roughly half of our firm so it's a
pretty good deployment
we'll just do one more here um from
frank what was your
workflow when designing the ui for the
shiny app how did you make sure the data
was presented in a useful way to the
bottoms up analysts
that's a good question i i think i tried
it about three or four times and i
bounced back and forth between flex
dashboard
and shiny or just you know standard
shiny
if you can see oh they've taken the
slides off
i have two levels of tabs because
there's a group of information
that's related to stocks information
that's related to our portfolios
and each of those has tabs underneath it
and i had a hard time working that in
in flex dashboard so i went back and
coded it from the beginning
but i use this tool in our morning
meeting every day
it's up there we bounce back and forth
between bloomberg and this tool
and so i certainly get a lot of live
feedback with people having issues with
it or
or as i hear there's other data that
they'd like to see there i
incorporate that into the design thank
you very much everybody please
join me in thanking
you